let's write it down and then let's just
ask let's just tell the story of what
this vlog is saying right yeah yeah so
if I say log base 10 of 0.0001 okay now
I'm gonna purchase two ways firstly what
kind of machine do I have how fast is it
growing every unit of time it's getting
10 times bigger right every single
minute 10 times bigger then it'll be 100
then it'll be a thousand core is pretty
fast okay but I'm asking well how long
do I have to put it in the machine till
it's that small that's really really
small okay it's growing fast but I want
to know when it's small so right off the
bat I know the answer is not going to be
positive right I've got to go backwards
in time does that make sense I've got to
be smaller okay so now that I know that
the question is how much smaller okay
I'm going to take advantage of this
though here
okay ready watch I want to get this as I
want to put in scientific notation
basically yeah because 10 is the base of
scientific notation so this is log base
10 of how can i rewrite 0.0001 how can I
write that inside to be notation in
Nick's waltz basically 10 to the power
of minus 3 does it check out is it work
10 to the power of negative 1 is just
0.1 then 10 to the power negative 2 is
0.01 10 to the power of negative 3 is
only 0.001 I need one more zero so
therefore what's a give 8 minus 4 it's
okay your calculator can check this for
you this is why we're doing this okay
okay now facing the power log here that
negative 4 the power is just gonna hop
out the front right it's just gonna be
negative 4 times whatever's left over
which is log base 10 of 10 how long does
it take me to grow to 10 one minute
right just 1 so this is negative 4 times
1 which is negative 4
okay do you see how I fought through the
question and I use the metaphor not
understand what was happening
give me another one pick one see see
okay let's do that this one I think the
numbers are small enough that you can
just do this with me
right scuse me the question this is
asking is for a growing machine that's
all coupling my object every minute
that's 28 times bigger every minute
right how long does it take to get to 60
for its current size right well in a
time zero it's just this original size
at time one it's eight times bigger and
then at time 2 is 8 times 8 times bigger
which is 64 so I'm just going to say
that it's just two right if I wanted to
I could write 64 as 8 squared and then I
can do the same trick that I did up here
but I kind of don't into because the
numbers are simple enough all right
let's do one more let's do it let's do
end and it looks like a good disaster
but it's ok
okay they have a look at this right you
can clearly see I've got this number at
the front so which law does this look
like what does it look like it's leaning
towards this is the power isn't it you
see I've got a number at the front so
this is time going over and over and
over again so I can rewrite this first
term here I can put the power back all
right I can put it up there like so log
base ten off what's too cute two types
of two times two is eight
excellent so now I've got two logs and
I'm adding them first I'm going to get
eight times bigger then I'm gonna get
12.5 times bigger now if you want you
can reach me calculator but I happen to
know that eight times twelve point five
is the same as 4 times 25 you agree with
that that's a hundred so how long does
it take my decoupling machine to be a
hundred times bigger it's up to units of
time right because the road ten dollars
big in the first minute and then the
next time ten time to give that is 110
via so that starts for two again okay
are you comfortable with the idea it's
not that complex
okay let's have a how to go something
question three because question two is
more or less the same big quite a
question really I think one anyway H of
course we go the age of course we go
from the hottest one all right let's get
there yeah before we write down the
question which is usually the first
thing we do you notice the question
three begins that give you a on a piece
of information right they say log base
10 of 4
it's that zero point six zero to one
ever prostrate okay now just before I
move any further this is actually
approximately correct can you see why
it's approximately crate my machine is
growing at a rate of 10 times every
minute right I know that after one
minute I'll be there for how big ten
times bigger but I only want to be four
times bigger
that's like much smaller than that I
don't want to go to a whole minute right
that's why it's part of a minute does
that make sense like I don't even need
to wait for the end of the 60 seconds
okay so they give you this piece of
efficient and then they say what do you
make of this okay excuse me whenever you
get asked to solve something and they
tell you a piece of information what you
want to do is get what you've got in
terms of that piece of information right
if I can rewrite this something like
this then I'll be okay right so for
starters let's have a look at this thing
square root of 40 that's a bit gross how
can i rewrite that in index form
what index is the square root pair of
what it's the power of 1/2 okay so you
might notice I keep on asking what's
that an index for what's that in explore
because more than Exponential's right
Lord's an index or just reverses of each
other so if this is something which I
hmm a bit slow to do this like I said
don't worry about log just go back to
your index laws okay go back to them
okay dad this I've got power right
you've got a power hang up up here so
what can I do with this power you can
bring it out over here so I get this
okay this is good I'm getting close up
right but I'm still not there yet 40 40
what do 40 and
or have to do with each other well forty
years four times ten is it not four
times ten so I'm gonna rewrite this as
1/2 log base 10 of 4 times 10 care of
that so far now why did I turn this into
x why did I do that and the reason why
is because right here if I have a
product in here if I'm multiplying two
things together I can break it apart
into two logs you see that one log break
it into two okay so when I rewrite this
I've got half and one of the two logs
that I've got kind of adding together
log base 10 of 4 that's good that's good
Plus what's the other one
base 10 of 10 and that's also good
because log base 10 of 10 is just 1
right so I've got 1/2 times that thing
plus 1 your calculator can do that for
you okay
can you see we had to do quite a 50s
there we have to get busy index form
okay we had to see oh I should break
this apart so I can use this law then I
had to use it and then I had to evaluate
based on what okay